good afternoon I'll be telling you about
how to privately learn half-spaces we
are finding privately finding a center
point of a set of points this is a joint
work with Shyamalan kabini seaman Oh
HTML all of them are present in the
spoon so what am I going to do in this
talk but first big speaking about
private learning of our faces or given
overview
they are not give define privately
learning of a center point at point in
the set in the convex hull and at center
point which I will properly define
overview and the algorithm then I'll
show a reduction from a private learning
of half spaces to finding a point in the
convex hull and as a result we get the
private learning algorithm for ha spaces
taken from a grid it's to the beat for
finite set s the sample complexity which
is polynomial in the dimension and very
madly depend on the size of the grid so
it's true to the order of log star of
the size of the grid and we will be
speaking about the setting without
margins of the dependency on lobster X
in the section so let's not talk him
about private learning of half spaces so
let me call very briefly the notion of a
private learning defining the cleaners
paper again we have the records of
people taken from some distribution it's
were coded it's labeled by they were one
we have the learning algorithm that
produces the hypothesis and we want to
the algorithm to be private it should be
a fast learner algorithm it should the
hypothesis should be good on the
distribution and it should be the
differential privacy
meaning that if we change one point the
you know the processes would be similar
at some Delta similar so this is public
learning in general let speak about then
hospitals
first with a pharmacy we have the set of
points in our to the D we want to find
in our half space that separates the
points points so the our faces will be
or this point or one side of this this
case in line but it's in our to the
diesel engine is the hyperplane so we
want to the half way to classify
correctly all the points and I'm
thinking about the classifying correctly
very simple but this implies the fat
learning in general so this is a permit
this is learning how spaces we will want
to be able to privately learn how spaces
so in this case we have a set of label
points taken from some grid X to the B
for some finite set X and it contains a
picture that B doesn't have to be
uniform the point the point of the grid
can be in different distances and we
have the label the porch from the screen
and we the goal is perfectly fine the
half space that separates most of the
points correctly and if what do I mean
by father's I mean that it's one point
moves location moves to the distribution
of the output of the algorithm jihad the
half spaces argue with the maternes
should be the similar distribution so
again if we have a privately learning
for that label correctly most of the
points in the sample so we have a
private back lining of the entire
distribution we have the generalization
error because give it to us so a few
remarks in this talk I'll assume that
the sample surface sir separable with
the half space that label correctly all
points our
discuss it in the few slides that we can
do although the case that it's not
reparable yes is it necessary to assume
extras idea or can you have different
set any port that petite bunk matter you
can take all that the union of the set
said to be agreed so it doesn't matter
we depend on blocks down the size of the
domain it doesn't matter and actually we
can think about not taking from a twig
by taking from some set of points it's
without loss of generality general
generality so unlike the previous talk
we assume there's no margin for the
points can be as close as possible to
the we protect both the dot on the label
so we can it's a point move in the in
the grid where so without changing its
label so we still have to have the
output distribution to be similar and
the last remark that we study this in
several complexity of this problem so
definitely argue it will have a such
example complexity but we want I'm gonna
be efficient for some cases it will be
an old discuss eternal bandits in a few
slides
so what is known for previous results so
without policy we know that this problem
can be learned with sample of size order
of 1 points but epsilon privacy that
financial mechanism is used a sample
complexity order d squared log X I'm
only I'm selling to now and I will in
this talk ignore all Greek letters or is
not the learning and the learning pal
matters and a big and the participant
matters all of them may be able
they expect I do expect them to do and
it could be that my thought of making
changes after my quarter very sort of
slides so yes so epsilon privacy we can
do it with order of d squared log X and
by your work of Italian David show with
this is the matching low bound so d
squared log X are necessary sufficient
to learn half spaces with epsilon
privacy this financial mechanism in
general is not efficient if you want to
have efficient algorithms so we can look
use the statistical a query model so SQL
the written for half spaces of done
Donegan and even paulo and we can
achieve use it to have a private I'll do
team with time and sample complexity
polynomial in D and log X where the
degree of D is at least four and if we
have margin which still be it was
discussed by mark earlier so we bla
metallic object if we can do it with if
with the margin we can do it by square
root of D of gamma squared with gamma
I'd imagine and recent results showed
that you can do it with sample
complexity one over gamma squared
without the dependency on the dimensions
the point is that they'd be dimensional
so the number of a possible to the
disparate because the point of Dido
maybe asides me I made this mistake a
few times and I always a return to yes
so this was for general D what is known
for the simple case of D equal one so
for epsilon privacy we still have the
same log X up and lower bound for
epsilon Delta privacy we can do it much
more efficiently we can do it in the in
the sample complexity 2 to the power of
log star X so it has a very much
dependency on the sides of the grid this
was first done by a copy over in myself
and another algorithm of given by bonnet
on and the lower bound of a Omega blocks
of X the first phabang are for the
proper case and then Bonnie needs
another proof in a space heater this and
very recently a little generalize this
know about for the also for improper
learning of half spaces of a twisted
function I will discuss this in this
talk tomorrow
so this shows that some dependency on
the size of the grid is essential
especially this particular discipline
earning threshold and half spaces over
there wheels is not possible you cannot
learn special aspects of infinite domain
because the size of the sample had to be
depend on the size of the grid and
another important thing in the risotto
by bonnet and the prove that under
differential
they prefer learning of threshold is
equivalent to finding an interior point
of a set of points let's motivate our
results so let's discuss what is finding
a military point again we have a set of
points taken from some some some finite
lead and we have to find a point between
the minimum of the maximum point so this
is the finding the ATO point and the
bomb approach so far we applied that
financial mechanism to this problem so
the exponential mechanism through the
point X from the grid which probability
e to the power epsilon times the Q of X
over C the Q of X is some quality
function and see the simply constant to
make this the sum of the probabilities
b1 so this is the financial mechanism
and to apply that we need to know what
is the quality function so the quality
function in this case is the closest
wellness to the medium in other words
it's a minimum number of sample points
that we need to remove such that it is
not invent interior point for example in
this case if we remove these three
points the red point won't be in the
airport of the remaining parts of the
quality is V if we would have taken a
point in this segment the quality would
before so this is the quality function
that we that we can define and what is
important is that the sensitivity of
this function is 1 if we move one point
from the one location from different
location the closeness to the
median will change by postman it can
increase or decrease by postman so this
is sensitivity one that's why we can
defer to the financial mechanism of
eternity of X over C and the sample
complexity of this simple algorithm is
order of log X the number of possible
candidates for set for that algorithm
can return
questions okay so let's continue so this
as I said did the epsilon-delta
algorithms at this point with the sample
complexity much more efficient so what
is I
without in a hospital we show an H on
Delta perfect algorithm for learning
hospitals with the sample complexity in
order B to the power four point five
times two to the power of log star of X
so for constant B these are this
basically the same sample complexity at
the algorithm the previous algorithm for
D equals one
so Big B the dependency of disability
miss worsen direct financial mechanism
but the the dependency of the size of
the grid is much better
we'll be in that problem but actually
learning is efficient algorithm is not
efficient so we have to compare to the
dictates financial mechanism which
unfortunately which is fortunately we
cannot match the dependency on D but but
at least for constant D which is already
equal to D code 305 is already a new and
we give much better sample complexity so
again there is a dimension and the
samples are taken from the grid X to the
D after now polka dots of a logical case
the result of Cobie over myself from so
the 15 if you have a private algorithm
for learning in the realizable case we
have the learning algorithm for
diagnostic case with the same sample
complexity so when we don't care about
the running time of the algorithm
agnostic and realizable learning private
learning equivalent so the same result
are the Wittenberg's also for the
agnostic case with the same sample
complexity and if we consider a constant
D and not a general bit like that we'd
want to the T to the be the random time
of our debate will be polynomial in log
of T so this is so concept in a nice
grid argue a tamara is the running time
is very efficient
so this the part of the overview about
private learning let's discuss you move
to the second part
poverty learning point in hospice a
profit learning point in the converter
so what is the problem we have a set of
points in a X to the B a set of the
points inside the bit X to the B and the
task is to find a point inside the
convex hull of the point and the point a
so we example we can choose the bed
point and the part of the point my may
or may not be in excellently so the
output of the algorithm doesn't need to
be in the grid and actually I'll do a
complete algorithm that will prevent or
not we turn up for until the grid and we
want to argue with them to be private
but that would mean that will be far and
private if we move some point and this
changes the convex hull the distribution
of the project which others should be
similar to be epsilon did that a similar
so we want a algorithm the changing the
location of one point doesn't change you
match the output of the algorithm
so this problem wasn't considered
previously sir could not tell you them
in the private setting important
consider viously
in the non private setting you can
simply return some point from the input
so I cannot tell you but previous
algorithm but I think the first thing
that I would try is try to apply their
exponential mechanism so again that
financial mechanism will to the point X
was probability e to the power epsilon
cubed over C and we have to ask
ourselves what is the quality function
and we need this sub function with such
small sensitivity and the problem that
that will happen was that the candidate
for the point X so to define the quality
function I have to define the talkee
talkee death of a set of points so the
Tokido for the point would be fine but
took in 75 the input is the set of
pointing out to the D and the toki death
is of a point X in our to the D is the
minimum number of points from s that we
need to to remove such that X will not
be in the convert all of the remaining
points so this is similar to the way
that we define the quality function for
the equal one so example if I take this
red point how many points do I have to
remove that to the point one being the
convex hull
I got the 44 mm 500 so if I remove all
the point to the right of the line it
was the bad part one big convex all of
the remaining points one comment so this
notion is you've been geometry and they
you redefined it they have a more
geometric definition but for us this is
the correct way to define the tendons
understand I will use the token
so for instance if you take all the
points outside the convex hull all of
them had to key depth zero or the point
in the convex hull has took this greater
than one at least one so if you want to
return a point in the convert convex
hull it's enough to put a little bit in
a point let's talk about greater than
one and four in this case if all the
points in the red polygons have took it
off at least two so it's again it's a
polygon with had stranger nodes but
these are the points of a deficit - so
this is it Toki death in this case and
the Tokido the very nice property that
will nude so for every set s in our to
the B with the point X in art of the day
such hood Toki death is at least s
divided by D plus one so let's see that
this is with the ball if he takes D
equal to a big put one in the median
that what it said but it was generalized
to to every dimension one point one
problem that will have that the pointed
guaranteed is not point of one point on
the sample but it will be any son
pointing out of the day so for instance
if you take this red point we have nine
points in our to the two so will its
cookie dough is at least three in this
case is 4 so we guaranteed that we'll
have it a point of the death tokido free
and it had the Tukey before and to
definitions the two comedian of a set of
points is the point X in R 2 the day
with matter with maximum two key death
among all points in out of the day and
the center point is a point X in after
the day for Sookie dirty
at least F of a [ __ ] one so we're
fighting that in the films that are
mentioned every set of s in add to the
day hadn't set apart so finally you can
then sign the title of the talk if the
points are points on the circle for
instance you have to take a point in the
middle so as I said this will cause us
problems that we'll have to deal with
when we design the algorithms so going
back to the financial mechanism we know
what is the quality of the function the
quality function we will use is a to P
death and this function had sensitivity
1 if we move one point from one location
to another the number of points that we
will need to remove can increase or
decrease by one so this is a good nice
function as I said the problem that we
know that's at the point which I took
either
it's nothing vague it's not even if
there it's not in the sample even if you
take a point from the grid it's not
necessarily in the grid so we we have to
have this small set of candidates so to
have the financial mechanism I know I
want to go into detail but thankfully
the geometry helps us and it said that
there's a small set of side x to the
deferred the cube such at all the two
consented lines for all points of the
grid for sets that are contained in the
grid are contained in the society so the
small set that we take can take as
candidates
if you apply that financial mechanism
the complexity will be DQ time log X
where the Big D to the 4 no T cubed
where D 3 D 2 cubed comes from the sides
of the set and another factor of D come
from the fact that the Tukey depth is
only n over a over D so we lose another
factor of D because the quality we know
I'm not in geometry and I'm not clear 50
it might be I think it's true but I'm
not if you can show me better would be
happy but I'm not - this is what we know
and later will be dependent the love
stuff so we didn't matter bother to
talked about this so this is so okay so
bottom said the way we know how to
implement financial mechanism this is
the best we know maybe with a little bit
more geometry we can improve it slightly
but not too much so what is our results
we show an epsilon Delta profit or do it
in four that's right so every set s the
site of s is big enough we find the
point with with a point whose took his F
is at least s divided by 2 D plus 1 so
if we won't have this factor D it would
be a center point - this is the
approximate center point and the
complexity of the side of the set s the
sample complexity of the problem is D to
the power 2.5
to to the North Star of X so we'll have
the complexity that we want that we can
achieve the dependent field on the side
of the domain and it would be D to the
power of 2.5
in particular this private algorithm
returns appointing the controller and we
put blow bombs every algorithm the
algorithm for the problem for absolutely
every actual data five star Gautam for
finding a point in the convex hull its
size of lesser to be Omega D plus lost
of X the be with new and the lots are
fall off of the lower bound for
threshold for the interior point and if
we only care about if we would want a
from differential privacy so the lower
bound is bigger d squared longer it's
finding a point convict on yeah for the
again this is an example of a problem
that they in the non private case you
can beat any point from the sample you
enough that the sample size of sample
will be one but in this case we have to
work a little bit to prove the law but
it's not
so let's go into the details of
algorithm so how do we can have to find
a pointer the dimensional point with
high to key death so we will find the
point coordinate of the after coordinate
and we'll settle this explain how to
find the first coordinate and the other
coordinate will be found
similarly so we we define a quality
function Q from R to n if it's inputted
the first coordinate of the turkey death
of the two key of the point and the
quality function is y in the two key
death of the best extension of Y to
point in R to the day so we take the
maximum of all points y 2 to y be the
Tukey death with y and the extension so
the best extension possible for the for
the point were you and what do we know
we know that the center point we know
that's a point with two key Depp at
least s over D plus 1 and if you take it
first coordinate the quality of this
point of Y will be s over D plus 1 and
what we find and I'll say something
about how we do it we find a point x1
put polity not at foremost but we had
some deterioration s over 2 times B plus
1 squared so we lose something in the
quality of the function there was the
point we find by differential privacy we
have to do something
it is related to one dimensional two
thresholds we back to slides and in
general we do in the D dimension for the
four coordinates we want to find this
point x1 to XP so for each I equal one
to the day we defined a quality function
which is the same as the previous
quality function but in this case we'll
have well the first I - find the
coordinates the coordinates of we
already found this is one wide that we
want to find the quality of define the
quality of and we look at the best
extension to point in our to the B so
this is a quality function cube i with
respect to the previous points that we
orbit coordinates that we already found
the induction will have we have a point
he pitches what is guaranteed by the two
key death - i minus 1 times this
something that we load and we know that
this the such a point and we will lose
another factor of s of A to B plus 1 so
in each step you lose this quantity of
it after these steps we found the point
X 1 to X B whose quality is a to T of X
1 to X D we don't have the maximum
anymore anymore and if we sum up what we
lost we lost at most half of this
quantity so we left at the point to the
death with at least s times s divided by
2 D plus 1
so this is algorithm but the didn't
point tell you how we find find this
point each coordinate so how do we
define the coordinate I'll say how we
find X 1 but it's only to simplify the
indices so again we have the quality
quality function and to find a goal is
to find positive find X 1 such that y 1
of X 1 is high and what we do we use the
algorithm of algorithm from 2015 we're
concave that funds X 1 with good quality
so this this is algorithm that we use to
solve this threshold so we use the same
algorithm but in this case we use the
coordinate of the core denied after
coordinate I think this welcome cave
algorithm is a very interesting tool
that has been used by the threshold than
by oven code before clustering and I
think it had many more applications that
and people are not aware of but so let's
say claim the property of this algorithm
the FIR move that we pulled if we have a
function I'm writing specifically the
function is the quality function depends
on the sample and on the x which is the
point in our it had to be some equality
concave which I'll define in the next
slide it had to have sensitivity 1 and
the size of the sample must be a CLE to
the to the power log star X this is
where we lose the fact of 2 to the power
X if you had such a function then a
welcome carry input s
find that when you add such a cube it's
close to the maximum possible value the
sample complexity would depend on the
amount of blows required so what was the
concave function so we call that the
function is concave if we have a B and C
so the value of f of B has to be above
the line connecting the a and B this is
a concave function a chronic concave
function can be much a mere creature and
what we require that if we have a B and
C the value of f of a so B has to be
bigger than the minimum of these two
points the Ferger function so this will
have to be bigger than the minimum in
other words the function has to be non
decreasing in the first part and non
increasing in the other port can have a
plateaus but it cannot have a local
minimum besides it cannot have local
minimum or not the definition so the
same and actually when we applied it to
for the learning the values were there
so it would stay so don't have to it's
nany nany decreasing and then non
decreasing but it can be can be like
this yes I'll go work for one dimension
functions and what we managed to do that
when we do it for the night of the
coordinated to learn something is to
find to optimize the D dimensional
function so let's see a simple example
really how am I was a time
ten minutes Lister legs on so how about
when do the salt so okay so I'm a good
on this time so what they wanted to show
an example of why the concave function
is the toka death for the case the
equals one so we have the point a with
in this case it's cookie death before if
we remove this point it won't be the it
won't be in the interior point and we
have two points B and C so the cookie
death of B is greater than the Toki
death of C because if we removed we have
to remove this point in particular to
makes it be not in the tail point you
have to remove the point of C and if the
toka death of a would have been less
than C we would have the symmetric
argument so for D equals one it's easy
to see that the toki death directedness
of the median is called the concave
function and this is how we can apply
algorithm to find the point in the
interior point into a point which is
equivalent to learning a recursive
function so as I said if we want to find
X 1 we use the Welcome algorithm to
apply that we have it we have two
challenges that we have to deal with we
have to prove that a function Q 1 or Q I
that we defined is called concave we
have to use some geometry to prove that
and we need to discretize them
mein as I said we know that at the point
in our that that is the center point and
not on admid so we had to use the same
without that I showed before the
generation of that showing that we can
choose x1 from a small fairly small
discrete domain so this is the idea of
finding a point in a center point so
conclusion we have an epsilon Delta
algorithm that works aside for set side
of side polynomial and B and 2 to the
load sub X and find the point with large
tokido to approximate center point at
over to 2 times B plus 1 so this is what
we know about the convex hull and this
and the second photo but the second part
of my talk and so let's go to the third
part of my talk we want to learn half
spaces using by showing the privacy with
the preserving reduction for blending
half spaces to finding a point in the
convex hull so we have we have a private
algorithm for finding a point in the
convex hull we use it at the black box
we will have a reduction we take which
which takes a set of lab labeled example
and construct a set of points fit this
into the algorithm this algorithm we
turned the point and we will understand
this point of the heart space that we
return so again the Banat I'll show the
reduction for the case D equals 1 this
reduction doesn't work for at least we
don't know how to make it work for the
bigger than 1 so we show a different
reduction which is very more complex so
how do we with the reduction worth we
use the sample energy great approach so
we take in large enough sample subsample
and for each one known privately we find
a
sisters have space for this some temple
so so after this step two we have L I
thought help and half spaces for each
sub something and now we have two
perfectly combined them into one into
one hypothesis in the to one high half
space so we take a convex all the point
in the converter of these hot places so
we look at the half space at the D plus
one for pointing deep out to the D plus
one and we have n points in our to the
deep earth one and we find the point in
the convex hull and this is that what is
that we return so let's sign in to Freud
right that's it good so what question
here
in particular it suppose you could just
practically release any of them and
you're gonna be good right a non-profit
are we complaining right I understand
that they're non private but it stays
and how magically they would they would
all have the accuracy guarantee you want
any single one of them right actually
we'll need them to have a much better
actor than we need non privately yes we
can return algorithm with the fact the
problem that we need to return someone
or something with privacy so first
especially think that we needed the
sample an aggregate if we take the sub
samples and we change one point so
instance we have this point here that
moved from year to year so only one
hypothesis would change so every sample
I mean I bring sub every night doing
samples will change one hypothesis this
means that we need that it's enough to
find to construct a private algorithm
with inputted half-spaces if you're
protective privacy of these and hospices
will protect the privacy of the original
sample so this is what is usually done
in the sample and aggregate so this is
good we have to find to combine h 1 to h
in a private manner so how what why is
sufficient to take part in the convex
hull so let's stop having to imported to
half places so finally towards the end
of the macaques or the forgive the
formal definition of the half space so
half space is determined by deeper deep
very even to a B and W and the
hypothesis gives one if an only if she
said the son a I X I is bigger than the
W so this is h1 and we have another
proptosis with the point one point two a
B Prime and W Prime so again if you turn
brown if the sum is bigger than W prime
and now we take the average of this to a
half basis so we take to the called
0.5 a 1 and we open v prime and so on
and we multiply that by X 1 and we take
the average of the weight of the weight
W so this is the average of two
hypotheses and if we have two half
spaces that gives the same value a then
the average give the same value to a two
to this point meaning that if these two
values give the correct value according
to the target function to the point X so
the Abbott also gives the correct value
to the pointers
nothing special but I think we can take
any combination conduct on combination
of these the processes and we can do it
for many hypotheses so if you take each
agent I want to HL all correct on the
point X then every convex combination of
this or processes is correct on X in
other words if we take a convex
combination the error of the resulting
potus's will be the sum of the earth of
each hypothesis so if you take all of
them to have smaller forces at smaller
error so the resulting H will have a
small error and I said this is the
generalization error so this is the
reduction as I said in this case we know
to prove that well the sum of these
errors we have a better analysis if the
if we put not take any not just a convex
combination if you take a point beside
to key death then the error would be it
would be left in the Sun and you think
this without you know the analysis we
get the algorithm of learning for in the
complexity of D to the power of 4.5
times analog of the to to the log of
zooming
so conclusion we show how to publicly
find the point in the convex hull which
height okey death the sample complexity
would be Polly the times 2 to the log
12x we prove a nobleman sample
complexity of this task and we privately
and use this to publicly learn their
half paces with the same sample
complexity at the feds we think it's we
have a poly be time to the lodestar we
have similar lobe on the open problem is
to prove the dependency on D the lower
bond is in this case it's d plus log
star can be removed we prove it from D
to the 2.5 today and if we remove it to
improve the finding this complex of this
problem will improve the complexity of
our learning algorithm questions
[Applause]
no questions
take almost again
[Applause]